and the very determinateness the stem
type the the being determined
by the way i got a
just a little bit of a digression here
what are these these are suffixes right
and we use suffixes like that to
indicate a kind of substantive that is
going on where we take an adjective or
we take a verb and we turn it into a
noun and a noun is supposed to name a
thing right but this is a thing about a
thing it's really a quality of the thing
the quality of determinateness insofar
as it has determinateness it's just like
everything else that is determinate that
possesses
determinateness so we don't want to be
seduced
too readily by language into thinking
that well it's got determinateness so
that must be something
because what's going to happen is the
thing
by examining what it means for it to be
determinate as we've just done in the
previous passages
is showing us to be
no thing
not a thing at least in the sense of
being something that can be totally
independent of all of its relations with
with everything else
at least it doesn't have an essence at
this point or being for itself
we saw that it did
but it's being for itself is mediated so
it's better to say not that it doesn't
have any essence or that it doesn't have
being for itself but rather it doesn't
have it simply it doesn't have it per se
it doesn't have it the way that we
wanted it
to to have it we've experienced
something in there necessity means quite
often you don't get what you want right
and so consciousness is having that
experience right now
people do this in all sorts of ways when
they start thinking about what is my
legacy
uh this is kind of a digression but it's
worth thinking about in in terms of this
this passage
when a person thinks about their legacy
they they typically say what am i
leaving behind
all right and they tend to focus on
achievements
achievements are things that our
activities bring about or they focus on
the example that they left their
existence and their activities right
or they focus on something a bit more
vague you know
i improved my my city i left behind
children who are well raised that's all
very well and good
but why does that legacy matter
i mean think about this
if you're leaving behind it will take
children for an example so you raised
some good children or you were a teacher
you raised you elevated some great
students to the level of being
professors themselves well who cares
i mean what is their value well they had
some great students as well and they had
some great students as well and pretty
soon if you do that long enough you
start to see that this chain is just a
chain of things that ultimately don't
have value and purpose in and of
themselves
but only in relation to something else
so for example socrates why did socrates
matter coming into being in the
activities that he engaged in well he
was the teacher of plato and plato was
the teacher of aerosol this is the sort
of stuff we tell each other in history
books and when we do preliminary
lectures right and then aristotle well i
don't remember who he taught but well
theo theo frostus and then people like
and you start to see that it doesn't
really matter unless there's something
intrinsic that these guys connected up
with
well what is that
that's something eternal something
unchangeable
a lot of times people want to uh you
know this is a little bit of a
digression here but it's kind of
important when we talk about idealism
idealism has come to mean something
quite different in modern parlance than
it did in you know uh you know earlier
times when hegel was was using and
taking the term you know from others
before him like kant for example
um and a lot of people associated with a
kind of you know fuzzy headed uh you're
living in the realm of ideas you're not
practical you're not grounded in things
that really are you know like like books
or
or neckties or chalkboards things that
you can touch things that you that you
can say thoughts about right
and what we forget in that
this is really one of the great insights
of the hegelian philosophy
is that ideas
are also realities
ideas have to be drawn out the notion
you know when it first comes on the
scene is not fully developed
but ideas have a kind of power you can
unfold them into reality and it's not
just an application of our thought
to reality
our thinking is a real thing
our thinking is itself part of reality
it's not something totally opposed to it
or you know it's got sort of a hazy
picture of it
um the for consciousness has some in
itself to it and so hegel is insisting
that we recognize this
you